antonio senzatel leading the rockies out
onto the field as we celebrate uh
military weekend and senza
as uh hughie made the remarks a few
moments ago his second starts it's
coming off the injured lift castellanos
in his last three games seven for his
last 13.
hard ground ball right on through
[Applause]
one ounce single rarely do you see
nick castellanos where he's not on a
fastball naked hit third for the first
time as a red yesterday he does so again
today everybody calls his last name
naquin
and we heard it was actually
not keen but nobody ever says it
so his last name is actually
not keen
the rockies could twist one
yep that's double play 4-6-3
well done
there's censor getting the ground balls
let's take a look at how things have
broken down for jeff hoffman in his
first four starts his last three starts
presented by western and southern what's
the difference beyond the numbers why
are the numbers looking like that i i
think a lot of it has to do with not
attacking the strike zone early in the
count
a four
pitch walk a couple rippies out there
down for hampton payoff
fly to routine left shogo akiyama makes
the catch
and hoffman strands a pair
shift is on hey eugenio suarez first
pitch swing that's deep in the right
center gap that's scott carey all the
way to the fence suarez steams up to
second as he hammers a double to deep
right center field and the reds have
their first extra base hit of the day
suarez moves up to third base on the
ground out with one out now shogo
akiyama
bouncer he's got speed story has no play
suarez scores infield hit for shogo
akiyama and the reds on top one to
nothing
right on right here and 2-1 this is back
up the middle redirected no you can't
throw them out
what a play by mcmahon
are you kidding me
it's like once a day
for ryan mcmahon making a spectacular
play
right off the glove matt gets it strong
across the diamond but hey let's give
him a little love too to connor joe with
the pick at the end
max bate two errors this year one at
second base one at third base
that'll bring up suarez who
scored the only run of this ball game he
doubled
check of second and the 2-2 pitch is a
one-hopper to fuentes at third goes to
mcmahon at second for one around a joe
for the double play
antonio senzatella closes out the fourth
with the twin killing
mack reached on a fielder's choice and
would steal second
in that first inning
this ball lifted to deep center field
and it's gonna touch down and roll to
the wall mcmahon hunting three now he
stops at second
good decision
a leadoff double for mack is tenth of
the year to go with the nine big flies
josh fuentes coming up puentes red hot
at the plate
man at second hamptons the trail runner
driven a left it's going to get down in
fair territory
is coming through again
hanson following mcmahon to the plate it
is a two-run double for fuentes
13 ribbies his last five games
colorado
100 second one out dom nunez up there
and nunez tags
fair ball
[Music]
see if we get a closer look
[Music]
chewing toe from this ankle see if the
ball disappears behind the yellow you
lose it right there you lose it for a
second but i think i'm gonna take
well disappointment for dom
trotted around the bases and either tap
on the shoulder it didn't count
another 3-2 and a great at bat nunez was
behind 0-2
had to refocus and he earns a walk
[Applause]
he's successful
here comes
nunez to third says zatella the second
three to one colorado
he just
i don't know he just kind of got
cavalier with the throw because he had
plenty of time costly error now two in
scoring position one out still and toppy
is at the plate
and tapia lifts this to shallow center
fuentes
is going to come down the line here's
the throw
excuse me nunez i said fuentes forgive
me so dom nunez the former middle
infielder
showing solid foot speed and the sac fly
off the bat at tapia to make it four to
two senzatella still at second with two
outs for connor joe
and he lines one towards center naked
comes on and he cannot field the ball
cleanly sends attella around second he
scores joe slides into second
and he has himself a base hit
and the rockies have another run
it is five to one
gianna vandazzazzo for two trying to
extend a hitting streak to seven games
and that's a base hit left center field
fuentes will head towards third
and this gets away for a moment here
comes josh to the play flip to second
that goes to right field
but then he overruns it oh my goodness
this is going to be one of those plays
you see in between innings
with the silly music by the base is
loaded
one ounce tyler naquin do up
well hit to center field base hit
india scores barnard given the green
light he
scores castellanos
claims third
two runs home as tyler naquin proves
clutch with the bases full a three-run
game and here is suarez
and suarez launches
deep center field caught at the edge of
the warning track castellanos scores
long sac fly rbi
the reds with a three spot in the eighth
they have crept within two shogu
has been a hot hitter
right up the middle center field base
hit naked given the wave hampson comes
up lobbing the second base the reds are
within a run
and their best bat is going to pinch hit
center field deep but playable and
hanson
in front of the track
makes the catch barnhart the tying run
the most pivotal hey eugenio suarez
coming to the plate
way up and it gets away barnhart breaks
and he scores
tie game
stevenson up there with a chance to give
the reds the lead nixon sells the go
ahead run over at third
and the dirt gets by again sends out to
the plate another run and the reds lead
a two spot in the ninth
seven
six
red legs and now you're really in a spot
here john because you've got one of the
faster guys in the national league
stepping to the plate i don't care if he
hits from the right side or not the
prospects of doubling this guy up
are slim and none
ground ball
india the second on the first
double play
and the reds win it
they double up one of the fastest men in
baseball and they roar back from down
five to win seven to six